l'entretien politique de ce mercredi
matin sur europe1 8h16 bonjour annie
genevard bonjour vous êtes la présidente
des républicains pas par intérim au nez
mais pas l air du doubs d'abord encore
une longue nuit à l'assemblée le projet
de loi de finances rectificative a donc
été adopté il y avait cette fameuse
ristourne sur le carburant de 18
centimes qui passe donc à 30 centimes en
septembre en octobre
ce compromis avec l'exécutif c'est une
victoire pour vous oui c'est une
victoire le fait que la majorité ne soit
que relative nous a permis d'avancer nos
propositions n'a obtenu beaucoup de
choses bon sur le carburant c'est une
mais ce sont des mesures auxquelles on
était attaché pour un favoriser ceux qui
prennent leur véhicule pour aller
travailler
qu'il était injuste de pénaliser le
gouvernement sur le carburant vous le dz
plus ciblé un il venait d est possible
et ce qui allait occasionner finalement
le l'évitement des classes moyennes où
nous avons le souci que les classes
moyennes souhaite aussi concernés par
les mesures de de pouvoir d'achat donc
de ce point de vue là nous avons obtenu
satisfaction mais ça va coûter plus
d'argent que prévu ou est ce qu'on
trouve cet argent alors dans le
gouvernement considère que dans les
pures général de 2,2 du budget ça passe
en tout état de cause
il est clair qu'il faut à la fois des
mesures de pouvoir d'achat et en même
temps ne pas dégrader substantiellement
les finances publiques il faut se
comporter de façon responsable ce
compromis c'est mieux finalement que la
proposition initiale de votre parti qui
était d'imposer un litre à 1 euro 50 7
et critique est d'ailleurs en interne
finalement son approche vous savez parce
qu'avec la ristournes consenties par les
pétroliers plus celle de total à puce et
luis de total qui probablement inspirera
d'autres pétroliers plus les 30 centimes
on arrive peu ou prou à 1 euro 50 donc
on voit bien que cette mesure qui était
décrié en réalité nous y arrivons parce
que quand on parle de pouvoir d'achat
parce que ce sont des mesures de pouvoir
d'achat il est clair que l'énergie
occupe un poste budgétaire de plus en
plus considérable dans le budget des
ménages et beaucoup de travailleurs
modestes qui font beaucoup de kilomètres
était quand même dans une très grande
difficulté c'est à eux que nous avons
pensé d'abord madame jeanne versys
l'essence restent chers après l'automne
vous reviendrez la charge vous et nous
verrons nous en serons à la fin de
l'année c'est vrai que ces mesures sont
limitées à l'année budgétaire 2010 22 on
verra ce qu'il en sera au niveau du
projet de loi de finances eu de 2023
mais cette question du pouvoir d'achat
elle et elle est prioritaire pour nos
concitoyens et nous aviserons le moment
venu alors ya les sens il y à la
monétisation des rétais la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires bilan de ce premier mois
de mandature plutôt positif même plutôt
positif vous avez rappelé quelques unes
des mesures par exemple le la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires la monétisation des rtt
ce sont des mesures de pouvoir d'achat
par le travail je crois que là on est
vraiment dans l'adn de la droite c'est
le travail qui permet de vivre dignement
et revaloriser le travail ça va dans le
bon sens c'est pour nous beaucoup plus
intéressant beaucoup plus fructueux que
que les revenus de de la substance il
faut bien sûr la solidarité
mais l'idéal c'est le travail et le
travail correctement rémunérés vous avez
profité du coup de la majorité relative
pour faire passer vos mesures
le risque pour vous et c'est de ne plus
apparaître finalement comme une
opposition très clair oui j'entends
j'entends ce que vous dites mais c'est
vrai que c'est une ligne de crête qui
est compliqué nous avons résumé cela par
l'expression être une opposition utile
utile parce que les français ne
demandent pas que nous bloquions les
institutions ne demande pas que nous
fassions le bazar à l'assemblée où dans
le pays mais que nous soyons tout de
même clairement dans l'opposition
toutes les mesures que vous avez rappelé
je pense à la dé conjugale isation
l'allocation adulte handicapé le
gouvernement n'en voulait pas sous la
précédente mandature il avait voté
contre donc là je pense que nous avons
fait oeuvre utile parce que nous étions
dans l'opposition
c'est pour ça que nous avons pu faire
faire valoir ces mesures mais vous
parler d'opposition utile de le risque
pas d'être une opposition finalement
gobé par le rn mais vous savez il ya
deux types d'oppositions et les
oppositions qui font le clash le buzz et
qui sont dans l'outrance et parfois dans
le mensonge et puis allez zou plus ici
écoutez chacun se reconnaîtra et puis il
ya les oppositions qui tout en restant
clairement distingue de la majorité
veulent être utile aux français et nous
aurons l'occasion de le démontrer alors
sur ses trois premiers textes de loi
nous avons obtenu beaucoup de choses qui
nous a amenés à les voter le quinquennat
n'est pas fini on va attaquer le dur ces
jeux vous dire la rentrée avec tout ce
qui touche à la sécurité qui a été quand
même la grande oubliée du précédent
quinquennat la réforme du marché du
travail tout ça c'est devant nous et
croyez-moi on jouera pleinement notre
rôle fait moi une confidence ce matin
est ce que vous avez sentiment d'être
une cible à la fois pour l'om pour le rn
mais également pour l'exécutif
clairement clairement je pense que les
républicains sont une cible de tous
côtés ce qui montre bien finalement
quelle est leur importance dans le
paysage politique moi je considère que
si les républicains
n'existait pas et bien la démocratie
française s'en trouverait singulièrement
et ça veut dire qu'il resterait un
grand centre un hypercentre et des
extrêmes et ça veut dire que la seule
alternative à emmen macron serait à
rechercher soit dans la nuque soit au
rassemblement national je ne crois pas
que la démocratie y gagnerait c'est la
raison pour laquelle on est très
attaquée de tous côtés mais on tient bon
année jeunes vers la présidente des
républicains ce matin sur europe 1 on va
parler à présent de l'avenir des
républicains après présidentielle et des
législatives raté on va le dire les
militants sont appelés à élire un
nouveau président dlr début décembre
vous assurez l'intérim vous serez
candidate
coûté pour l'instant je suis très
concentré sur ma mission elle et elle
est importante alors c'est une grosse
c'est une grosse maison il faut la
conduire je suis très attaché aussi à
veiller à ce que les candidats soient
traités de façon absolument équitable
j'ai engagé un travail important avec
les groupes parlementaires de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat parce
que il faut bien considérer quand on
parle des républicains et parlementaires
on a un groupe très important au sénat
avec lequel il faut travailler donc ce
travail de fond est important jeu c'est
la raison pour qu'ils y penser faites
moi une confidence vous y pensez concret
tests et bien sûr bien sûr c'est une
hypothèse que que je n'exclus pas mais
je n'ai pas je n'ai pas arbitrées et en
tout état de cause le temps n'est pas
venu pour moi le temps il est au travail
et à la concorde dans cette maison alors
il ya eu visiblement pour eric ciotti qu
annoncé sa candidature hier aurélien
pradié qu'était il ya quelques jours la
mélodie qu'il ait pensé sérieusement il
faut mieux miser sur la jeunesse ou
plutôt faire le choix d'une droite dure
c'est quoi aujourd'hui finalement les
républicains
moi je pense que si nous allons vers le
débat de ligne nous allons nous
affaiblir parce que chez les
républicains la grande famille du hmo
liste trouvez moi un français qui ne
soit pas attaché à la fois la sécurité
à l'autorité publique et en même temps à
la solidarité mais générac il il yal
vous faisais part j'ai français on l'a
bien vu la présidentielle ou à j-7 c'est
vrai c'est vrai et ça veut dire qu'il
faut changer beaucoup de choses il faut
faire souffler un grand vent d'air frais
dans notre dans notre maison il faut
renouveler nos pratiques politiques
il faut travailler à l'unité de notre
famille et c'est pour ça que ce ce
combat de l'hymne me semble porteur de
grands de grands dangers pour notre
famille politique il faut pas non plus
anticipé 2027 trop tôt je crois que je
vous entends il faut yaka concrètement
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire comment aura
sans doute ce qui est éparse
d'abord je pense que
il y a si vous voulez des sensibilités
différentes dans les candidats il y à la
façon dont on exprime les choses il ya
la priorité qu'on donne à tel ou tel
sujet mais sur le fond
je crois qu'il y a en tout cas chez tous
nos militants une aspiration à l'unité
et une volonté que tous soient prises en
compte tous soient traitées moi je ne
crois pas que parler de la sécurité
exclu tu parlais de la solidarité que
quand on parle du travail ça veut dire
qu'on néglige ceux qui en sont éloignées
voilà donc cesser son est loin quand
même de ce qu'était le projet de base de
l'ump de rassembler toutes les familles
de la droite vous savez
il y a dans notre famille politique des
sensibilités différentes vous en avez
cité 2
vous voulez juste la team nous avons
fait l'union et les centristes on nous a
dit moore un nombre de fois incalculable
et vous voyez que les non seulement les
républicains tiennent mais qu'ils jouent
pleinement leur rôle au parlement et ça
c'est très important une dernière
confidence encore est ce que c'est vrai
que des proches de laurent wauquiez vous
ont demandé de dissoudre totalement les
l air pour reconstruire une nouvelle
offre à droite oui alors je vais
recevoir puisqu'il l'a annoncé une led
aura drainé yankee
un jeune un jeune et leurs proches de
laurent wauquiez qui demande de
dissoudre les républicains bon c'est une
proposition pour le moins hasardeuse
pour ne pas dire un peu
étrange et je ne sache pas que laurent
wauquiez soit derrière cette proposition
vous savez les républicains c'est une
c'est une famille très ancrée dans la
vie politique et quilles âge le j'en
suis persuadé a un avenir et même si
nous avons enchaîné des difficultés
électorales incontestable des défaites
cruelles sur les quatre derniers
scrutins nous en avons quand même gagné
un certain nombre et
et imaginons imaginons que cette
proposition prospère alors ça veut dire
que nos députés nos sénateurs et qu'elle
a attaqué les familles politiques
appartient-il ça n'a pas de sens le on
l'a entendu difficile chantier de la
patronne des républicains annie genevard
députés l ère du doubs ce matin ce repas
merci à vous merci belle journée merci
merci